[Musique]
sept sénateurs ont écrit ce rapport là
une trentaine d'auditions sur la
situation des femmes à la piste vinolas
parce que on t'arrête on partait de loin
et on pensait que les choses étaient un
peu arrangé banon vous avez aux millions
de femmes qui vivent en milieu rural et
qui sont dépendants pour les deux tiers
d'entre elles sur des sujets financiers
mobilité de logement
des violences et de s'enrayer derniers
indicateurs santé je veux des six ados
nous faire réagir 13 départements en
france non plus le gynécologue de serre
la chine qu'aux logique un os sur
évidemment que je l'envoie prendre parle
énormément
vous savez les chiffres 1
aujourd'hui entre le salaire de
gagné par les femmes celui donné par les
orgues et 22 % d'écart
tout ça fait que mon ami à une
dépendance financière même comme ça ne
va plus dans la situation familiale et
l'enclume terme de violence puisque les
violences il ya la violence sous l
emprise et
la fameux exposés ne veut pas partir on
ne peut pas partir parce qu'elle est et
en dépendance ça aussi on en a eu le
témoignage dans de nombreuses revues
j'ai proposé est là où on a su créé des
correspondants défense coqueret aussi
dans nos conseils municipaux des
correspondants violente dire que
quelqu'un est là d'arbres conseil
municipal ce soir dans l'ombre au
conseil municipal ou désigner un élu
identifiée pour ça j'étais dans la
position
lancrel les faire rêver à voir
il ya dans les communes y compris dans
nos communes et chez bien que c'est pas
facile une parité à partir de 500
habitants à chaque fois qu'on permettra
plus de place aux femmes en
responsabilité nous apporteront plus de
pollution
[Musique]